it's tougher than any man-made material
it's a combination of strength and
elasticity no other material can
actually combine these two features
either material strong or it's elastic
and the spider self is both five times
stronger than steel spider silk has been
tantalizing the human imagination for
decades you want to be a Spider Man you
have to make fibers but we can't just
farm the silk because spiders eat each
other the scientists have pursued other
roots a DNA sequencing breakthrough in
Germany means manufacturing spider silk
fiber is no longer pure fantasy the next
step is really producing tons of the
material and all the offices we have
spiders and you know they are very like
pets we like to have them around we
think they're beautiful if a Nega
co-workers make your skin crawl
then the biomaterials lab at bioriod to
university probably isn't for you it's
here that professor thomas Schaible and
his team studying natural substances
like spider silk in the hope of turning
them into super materials spider silk
cares for a lot of material science has
been the holy grail for decades
if we take a thump thick spider fiber we
could actually get a jumbo jet holding
up in air without tearing it apart but
can withstand hundreds of tons of load
in full speed without breaking the best
silk produces or prevent spiders they
have seven different types of silk with
different properties we find dramatic
differences there concerning mechanics
but also concerning other properties
wanting to harness these characteristics
led to Sharples breakthrough and
genetically modifying bacteria to
produce spider silk proteins this
patented technology formed the basis of
an silk the company schaible founded
with a postdoc from his research lab Lyn
the bacteria were using us working horse
very simple organisms they only try to
grow and we exploit that we were feeding
them we give them perfect conditions to
live and they multiply and multiply and
afterwards we we changed their way of
living we give a trigger so that they
stop proliferating and they start
producing our protein after purification
we have protein in form of a white
powder and still takes the protein
powder and spins it into a fiber so what
you can see here is our spinning machine
very produce our BIOS the fiber which is
then transferred to the Yana who can
make the yarn and then later the fabric
out of the material
the material is a vegan and
biodegradable synthetic biopolymer
rather than use the bios steel material
in their own product and silk wants to
produce it for established brands who
have expertise
paddy - used it to create a concept
shoot an amiga made a special edition
watchstrap airbus are also exploring how
it can be used in aviation they know
their product we developed together with
them the product has a much higher
quality in comparison to what we could
do on our own the company has raised
millions in venture capital but
producing enough of the material is the
biggest challenge
yes it's very thin you need a lot of the
fiber in a normal sports shoe there are
more than 170 kilometers of this fiber
processed into the yarn and later the
fabric of the shoe the company says it
has made hundreds of thousands
kilometers of fiber so far but scaling
it up further will take time and money
but like the orb weaving spider which
uses different silks for different parts
of the web and silk is putting the
spider silk proteins to use elsewhere in
the beginning we had this great
innovation we had thousands of
opportunities how to use that for
industry and this was a beautiful
problem you can use it for different
applications and everyone had the
experience when he goes to the basement
that there might be a spider's web and
if it's an old house it might be there
for hundreds of years and it's not
degraded so the question is why microbes
have the big problem sticking to the web
if you'd lost in the woods get a web you
can use it as a wound coverage device
you can wrap your food you can actually
prevent your food from rotting for a few
days
the material is a proteinaceous material
we are all made out of proteins and our
body responds very good to the protein
and that's very suitable for
of medical devices we probably have more
than 80 different variants of silk
molecules that we can play with some of
them are very well suited for tissue
regeneration some of them are absolutely
the opposite we really just at the
beginning into understanding how this
material has evolved to actually feature
different kind of applications and
that's exactly what we want
am silk is building up production
facilities to make its material at mass
scale
it's hoping to capitalize on the
products broad potential and take a lead
in an industry harnessing the best
attributes of natural substances we are
living in a time where materials made
from proteins will become more important
every day
[Music]
you